yesterday we told you all about the
weekend being snubbed by the grammys and
now some heavy hitters have come to his
defense
yeah so fellow torontonian drake called
out the grammys saying they
no longer matter writing on his
instagram i think we should stop
allowing ourselves to be shocked every
year by the disconnect between impactful
music
and these awards and just accept that
once that what was once the highest form
of recognition may no longer matter to
the artists that exist now
and the ones that come after it's like a
relative you keep expecting to fix up
but they just can't change their ways
yeah drake went on to suggest that
maybe the grammys need to be replaced
and that this is a great time to create
an alternative show
saying this is a great time for somebody
to start something new
that we can build up over time and pass
on to the generations to come
yeah nicki minaj also reposted drake's
comments plus also having
the weekends back is sir elton john
himself posting on instagram in my
humble opinion
blinding lights song of the year record
of
the year so roz what do you think about
this do the grammys matter anymore
i think that the grammys still matter
because they matter to people they think
that they matter to artists regardless
of how much you say that they don't and
maybe it's time to move on the grammys
will always be
uh the grammys but i think that we go
through this every year as well with you
know best picture nominations
at the oscars and do the oscars even
matter and why is there such a
disconnect between
the golden globes and the oscars and why
aren't comedies ever considered
it's completely subjective and it's just
all up to taste and i know there's a lot
of people
that think that the weekend was
deserving but is he pop is he r
b how is he submitted there's all of
these things and maybe there's just
people
on the panel that couldn't find
something to take
off the list of things that were already
nominated there's a lot of people that
love the week and a lot of people that
love that track and a lot of people that
love that song
but maybe not enough yeah well it's
interesting that you talk about
rmb2 because you know justin bieber he's
been nominated um and his album changes
is nominated
in the pop category and he's actually
upset even though he's been nominated he
actually thought his album should have
been
uh represented in the r b category so
you're right i mean it really is kind of
like
what category could all of this have fit
in but what do you think of an
artist who calls out that they should
have been
nominated and weren't like what do you
what do you make about that it's a it
that it's really exclusive to music you
don't see a lot of actors
attacking the academy for not getting a
a a nomination um and it really is
it's it's all about music and even
arguing over what categories they're in
there's some people that don't want to
be they think that it's so ha somehow
lesser than to be nominated in the niche
category specifically rock or
you know hip-hop back in the day or rat
back in the day uh they want the big
ones they want song of the year record
record of the year and album of the year
uh but calling them out
i i don't know i mean i think i think i
think you're pissed off
and i i like when people are passionate
about this stuff i
always hated when people said awards
never mattered and they don't care if
they're nominated because
people do care and so there's a part of
me that likes this there's a part of me
that likes the feistiness
of all of this and they're sort of
ganging up and now elton john's involved
i kind of dig it i know i know that kind
of uh that kind of threw me off
too and then overall i mean obviously
the the
you know you you're always listening to
music you're always on that with your
radio show like
were you surprised yourself that the
weekend wasn't nominated
um no i wasn't i wasn't surprised
because i'm never surprised when
something doesn't get nominated
that's i think the reality of it when
you do this for as long as you do
these are not news stories there have
been grammy scandals my
entire life and you know
they try and do their best and figure it
out and say we've solved the problem of
all
and it's never solved and there's always
there's always grammy controversy that's
part of the grammys i think that that's
one of the things
that makes the grammys the grammys are
things like this
but who do you take off who do you take
off who do you take off the list that's
the other thing too is that if you're
going to put
um you know weekend on there and i'm not
saying he's not deserving because i
actually think that it is very deserving
but if you're going to put the weekend
on there the question is
then who do you take off it's true
so code red is saying the weekend and
the chicks were robbed
big time after hours was my pick to win
um uh jk is saying the weekend was way
above everything
in the rest in the top three his music
genre is not a problem in the general
area
um simpsons is saying be patient
as time will come underdogs are
celebrated even when
their big moment finally arrives uh sims
saying music is subjective
uh adrian's saying take off justin
bieber and mitch is saying let's just
eliminate
all awards overall come on how are we
gonna know how special we are
if we get rid of all the awards